in this video you're going to learn how
to multiply three binomials together
we're going to go through two examples
let's do the first one together and you
can try the second one on your own so a
binomial represents like two terms the
terms are separated by plus or minus so
you can see we have two terms times two
terms times two terms so what you want
to do is you want to pick two of those
binomials to multiply together first so
for example I'm going to take these
first two binomials here on the left and
what I'm going to do is I'm going to do
the distributive property twice so I'm
going to take this x right here I'm
going to multiply it by x x * X is X2
remember when you multiply you want to
add the exponents together so 1 + 1 is 2
then we're going to take x * -2 make
sure you capture the sign whether it's
negative or positive so -2 * X is
-2X then we're going to take this three
and we're going to distribute it so 3 *
X is positive 3x and 3 * -2 is -6 now
let's go ahead and combine like terms
the -2X and the POS 3x comes out to just
1 x let's bring down the X2 and the -6
okay so now we multiplied these first
two Tri uh two binomials together and we
got a trinomial now we want to multiply
it by this binomial here x + 5 now you
can do this a couple different ways you
could take x times all three of these
and then five times all three of these
that's one way to do it the other way to
do it is to take x^2 times these two
terms and x times these two terms then
-6 times those two terms either way
you're going to get the same answer I'm
going to do it this way I'm going to
take X and I'm going to distribute it to
x^2 so x * x^2 is X cubed remember
you're adding the exponents 1 + 2 then x
* X gives us x^2 because again we're
adding the exponents 1 + 1 is 2 and then
x * -6 is -6x now we're going to take
the five and distribute it to all three
of these terms so if I take five 5 * x^2
I get 5
x^2 5 * X I get
5x and 5 * -6 I get -30 now you don't
have to line them up the way that I did
here you can just put them in a row if
you want but the reason I did this is
just to kind of line up the X squ terms
the X terms Etc so it'll make it a
little bit easier when we combine like
terms so we've got X cubed 1 x^2 + 5 x^2
is 6
x^2 -6x + 5x is 1X and then - 30 and
again you want to write it in a
descending order from the highest power
down to the lowest and that's your final
result so let's take a look at another
example see if you can pause the video
in try number two here and we'll go
through it together now if I was going
to do it I would do the same thing I did
on this first example I'd multiply these
two binomials here on the left together
first you could do these two first or
the first and the third it doesn't
matter but you're just going to take two
binomials and multiply them together so
so I'm going to use the distributive
property twice I'm going to take the 2x
* X which gives us
2x^2 then 2x * pos2 is 4X then -1 * X
ISX and -1 * 2 is -2 let's go ahead and
combine like terms together so we get
2x^2 + 3x - 2 and then that's all
multiply by this binomial here 3x - 4
and so how would you multiply that well
let's take the 3x and we're going to
multiply it by all three of these terms
so 3x * 2x^2 is going to give us 6X
cubed again you're multiplying the
coefficients together and then the
variables together and then now 3x * 3x
gives us 9 x^2 3x * -2 is -6x and then
now we're going to take this -4 again
make sure you capture the uh whether
it's positive or negative and we're
going to take -4 times all three of
these terms
-4 * 2x^2 is -8
x^2 -4 * 3x is -12x and -4 * -2 is POS 8
okay so all we have to do now is just
combine like terms I'm just going to add
straight down here 6 x Cub +
x^2 - 18x + 8 is our final result and
you got it again you don't have to line
them up like this you could just put
them in a long row and then combine like
terms
and you got it so great job if you're
able to follow this video I'll put a
link to another video talking about how
to multiply trinomials together uh right
over there so I'll see you over in that
video and I I'll see you in the next
video